Traduttore: Peggy-Anne Berthier
Revisore: Michele Gianella
La bellezza di cui
vi voglio parlare io, invece,
è una bellezza che ha condizionato
radicalmente tutta la mia vita.
Noi -
io, personalmente, mi sono
sempre posta questa domanda:
Che cos'è la bellezza?
Non so se voi siete riusciti a dare
un vero e proprio significato
a questa parola.
Io, all'alba dei miei 30 anni,
ancora non sono riuscita a dare
un significato pieno a questa parola.
Però, so esattamente come questa parola
abbia condizionato, modificato
tutta la mia vita.
Sono nata e cresciuta in un mondo
dove la bellezza ci viene presentata
con dei canoni molto ristretti.
Dove la bellezza prevede
che una persona abbia
tutte le parti del corpo
al posto giusto, delle misure giuste.
Viviamo in un mondo dove la bellezza
ci viene inculcata 24 ore su 24,
attraverso la televisione,
attraverso le sfilate di moda,
attraverso le riviste.
I cartelloni pubblicitari
ci mostrano sempre donne bellissime,
donne perfette.
Viviamo in un mondo di bellezza apparente
dove, veramente, non è prevista
l'ombra di un difetto.
Quello che io mi domando è -
vi domando: “Io vi sembro perfetta?”
Cioè, basta guardarmi per capire
che io non ho tutto al posto giusto.
Mi piacerebbe.
Mi sono domandata,
quando ci siamo incontrati,
all'inizio di questa esperienza,
mi sarebbe piaciuto sapere
che cosa voi abbiate pensato di me
nel vedermi di primo impatto.
Perché, purtroppo, viviamo in un mondo
dove l'apparenza, a volte,
è il 90% della percezione di una persona.
Io sono qui oggi
per raccontarvi la mia storia.
E per farvi capire come in realtà,
al di là della bellezza apparente,
ci sia molto di più
da raccontare di una persona.
Sono nata e cresciuta
con un raro tumore alla retina,
che mi ha colpita
all'età di soli 20 giorni.
In realtà, già dal quinto mese
di gravidanza di mia mamma,
questo tumore, insomma,
ha iniziato a colpirmi.
La cosa più buffa di questa situazione
è stato che io ho imparato
a convivere con questa malattia.
Io ho imparato a convivere
con una disabilità
che mi ha portato via
quasi completamente la vista.
Io da un occhio non vedo nulla,
dall'altro vedo meno di un decimo.
Ho bisogno di aiuto, di sostegno,
nella vita di tutti i giorni,
per far anche le più piccole cose.
Non potrò mai guidare,
non riesco a leggere.
Insomma, tutta una serie di situazioni.
Ma ho imparato a convivere
perché questa è la mia vita.
È una vita in cui
si affronta una disabilità.
Quello per cui ho dovuto
lavorare veramente tanto
è stato invece riuscire
a convivere con la mia diversità.
L'essere diversa.
Ho iniziato da piccola a chiedermi
perché i miei compagni dell'asilo
fossero diversi da me.
O perché io fossi diversa da loro.
Questo tipo di ragionamento
mi portava, a volte,
a chiudermi in me stessa:
non avevo tutta questa
voglia di socializzare
o di mettermi in mostra
o di creare delle grandi relazioni.
Sino a quando, vivendo un'esperienza,
diciamo, un po' particolare,
in cui mi sono ritrovata
a dover scegliere di “buttarmi” nel mondo,
mi sono resa conto
che in realtà non tutte le persone,
non tutti i bambini nel mio caso,
erano, tra virgolette, cattivi -
quindi giudicavano, prendevano in giro
soltanto per il mio aspetto.
Ma in realtà c'erano un sacco di bambini
a cui il mio aspetto non interessava
e avevano solo voglia di fare
quello che fanno i bambini:
di giocare, di uscire,
di andare al parco, di divertirsi.
Ho avuto anche un'altra
grande fortuna nella mia vita,
che è stata quella di avere
una famiglia e degli insegnanti
che mi hanno fatto vivere
in un contesto assolutamente paritario.
Anzi, molto intelligentemente,
hanno creato delle situazioni scolastiche
in cui mi veniva permesso
di stare - al posto che fare
10/20 ore di sostegno fuori dalla classe,
era la classe che faceva
tutte delle attività didattiche,
più manuali, più tattili
in modo tale che venivano coinvolti
tutti i compagni in progetti.
E sono io diventata
la piccola mascotte della scuola.
Si perdevano un sacco di ore noiosissime
per fare invece dei laboratori
artistici grandiosi.
Abbiamo fatto anche
dei progetti, tra l'altro,
che sono stati poi esposti
in alcune mostre.
E quindi diciamo che questo atteggiamento
delle persone nei miei confronti
mi ha permesso di riuscire a comprendere
che potevo creare delle relazioni
anche con gli altri,
dei momenti di condivisione,
perché si potevano fare determinate cose,
anche se in maniera diversa,
però era fattibile farle.
E quindi, dal punto di vista, diciamo,
dei rapporti interpersonali,
ho veramente avuto una grande fortuna.
Ben diverso è invece il momento
in cui ti ritrovi a casa, a ragionare.
Dici, ok, ho una bella famiglia,
ho tanti amici, ho un buon carattere.
Però, poi, ti trovi
davanti allo specchio e dici:
sì, va bene, ho tutte queste cose,
sono una persona fortunata.
Però perché a me?
Cosa ho fatto io di male,
nella mia vita, per meritarmi questo?
Per avere questo aspetto,
per avere questa faccia,
per essere diversa?
Me lo sono chiesta un miliardo di volte,
mi sono domandata
se mai avrei trovato nella vita
una persona che era in grado
di amarmi e di sostenermi
per la persona che sono io, interiormente,
e non basandosi solo sul fatto
di essere diversa, di avere
un aspetto diverso dagli altri.
E vi posso assicurare che è una domanda
che ha fatto tanto male.
Ha fatto tanto male sentirsi giudicare,
sentirsi affibbiare nomignoli,
sentirsi dire dalle persone:
ma io fossi in te non uscirei di casa,
ma che vergogna.
Perché purtroppo, mi dispiace,
ma questa è la realtà dei fatti.
E quindi dovevo trovare un modo,
nella mia testa, per me stessa,
per volermi bene,
per riuscire a dare una risposta
a questa mia domanda.
E io questo modo l'ho trovato
attraverso la danza.
È stato come un interruttore.
Perché?
Perché la prima volta
che sono entrata in una scuola,
o comunque ho messo i piedi
su una pista da ballo,
sono riuscita a far scomparire
tutto quello che avevo intorno.
È scomparso tutto.
Se in quel momento io provavo
una grande rabbia nei confronti del mondo
perché comunque io entro in una sala,
è inevitabile, hai gli occhi
puntati addosso, cioè, è così.
E ve lo dico io che non ci vedo,
ma me li sento addosso -
(Risata)
Perché te lo senti addosso,
senti il bisbiglio,
senti la risatina, senti tante cose.
Nel mio momento di danza,
la rabbia che io provavo in quel momento
si trasformava in un’emozione così grande
da colpire le persone dritte al cuore,
per l'energia che arrivava.
Lì non ero più Elena Travaini,
quella che - che occhi che ha,
che faccia che ha -,
ma ero Elena Travaini:
ammazza, guarda questa come balla.
guarda come si muove. Wow!
Piano piano, perché comunque
c'è voluto tempo,
ci sono voluti veramente
sacrifici, allenamento,
prendevo sempre più consapevolezza
di questo mio, tra virgolette, potenziale,
di questa mia qualità
che mi permetteva di dimostrare al mondo
quello che io sono, come persona,
al di là del concetto, diciamo,
su cui si basa la bellezza.
Perché, alla fine, chi è che ha deciso
che la bellezza debba essere
la ragazza 90-60-90,
alta un metro e ottanta,
biondissima, con gli occhi azzurri?
La bellezza apparente
a me, per quanto mi riguarda,
nel mio percorso di vita,
mi ha veramente fatta soffrire.
Ma anche fatta crescere,
perché volevo dimostrare al mondo
che c'è qualcosa di più,
che non è solo quello.
E da una bellezza apparente
sono riuscita a passare
ad una bellezza emozionale,
una bellezza che, attraverso la mia arte,
crea emozioni nei confronti delle persone.
È stato un percorso
molto introspettivo, molto bello,
e allo stesso tempo anche molto difficile
perché, non pensate,
ma per una persona
che ha problemi di vista
riuscire a ballare non è proprio una cosa
subito fatta e molto semplice.
E anche qui ho avuto una grande fortuna
di incontrare quello che, attualmente,
è il mio compagno di vita
e anche il mio ballerino, Anthony,
che durante un percorso
che abbiamo intrapreso insieme,
di competizioni,
comunque dove hai tutta una serie
di regole ben precise,
dalle quali tu non puoi sfuggire.
Anche se sei disabile,
non importa niente a nessuno:
quelle sono le regole,
quelli sono i passi, quella la precisione.
E quello devi fare, punto.
Ovviamente, per me,
la cosa era molto complessa,
ho iniziato comunque ad andare in crisi.
Dicevo, ma come,
una cosa che amo così tanto,
che mi fa stare bene
inizia a trasformarsi
in un’emozione negativa.
Sono veramente andata in crisi,
cioè tornavo dalle lezioni in lacrime.
Fino a quando Anthony ha deciso
di voler provare insieme a me
un'emozione diversa.
Mi dice, ok, facciamo una cosa.
Voglio provare a ballare bendato con te.
Voglio provare a vedere
se, togliendo il senso della vista,
riusciamo a creare
qualcosa di buono insieme.
È stata un'emozione fantastica.
Uno, perché comunque è stata
la condivisione di una situazione diversa,
e un grande gesto d'amore
da parte sua nei miei confronti.
Due, perché in realtà anche qui
è scattato un altro interruttore.
Cosa è successo?
Che ballando insieme bendati
si è creato una condivisione
e una comunicazione,
un feeling tra di noi,
ancora più potente.
Le emozioni esplodevano proprio!
Le persone che ci hanno visto ballare
hanno sempre ripetuto questa frase,
che io adoro, dicendoci,
Voi due, quando ballate, create una magia.
Che penso che sia
la cosa più bella del mondo,
cioè creare una magia,
un'emozione così grande che fa sognare
penso che sia veramente
la più grande forma di bellezza
perché la magia crea un emozione,
dentro ad ogni persona, diversa.
Ogni persona se la vive a modo suo,
si emoziona a modo suo.
Questo cosa ci ha fatto capire?
Ci ha fatto capire
che la persona diversamente abile
può fare delle cose.
Una persona che non ha
nessun tipo di problema
e si pone nelle condizioni
che non sono quelle
a cui è abituato a vivere,
in cui è abituato a vivere normalmente,
può fare, può fare.
Anche se tu vai a cambiare
una situazione di normalità
e vai a togliere un qualcosa, puoi fare.
E qui cosa abbiamo deciso di fare?
Abbiamo deciso di portare
questo messaggio, questa esperienza,
e proporla alle persone.
Noi sono ormai sette anni
che stiamo insieme
e sono tre anni che abbiamo deciso
di creare questo progetto
che si chiama Blindly Dancing,
che proprio vuol dire
danzare ciecamente, o ballare al buio,
e abbiamo toccato le 120.000 persone
che hanno fatto questo tipo
di esperienza con noi.
È una cosa fantastica,
un messaggio molto potente,
un'esperienza che permette alle persone
di trovare la loro bellezza,
Trovare una bellezza
che esteriormente non arriverebbe mai.
Una persona, quando
si cala nel buio, balla.
Quindi è una condizione giocosa, gioiosa.
Non è un discorso pesante che, dove -
Vabbè, stavo dicendo, come in questo caso,
dove ci sono io che parlo,
parlo, parlo e voi ascoltate.
È un momento molto più interattivo,
ma soprattutto è un momento
in cui bisogna imparare
a fidarsi di sé stessi
e ad affidarsi completamente
a un'altra persona.
È veramente difficile.
È difficile calarsi nel buio,
perché calarsi nel buio
vuol dire imparare
a superare dei limiti,
mettersi in gioco.
Ma la soddisfazione più grande di tutte
è quando chi fa questo tipo di esperienza
arriva alla fine rendendosi conto
di aver cambiato qualcosa dentro di sé.
Il fatto di calarsi nel buio,
di farsi portare da un'altra persona,
di affidare le proprie emozioni,
le proprie paure,
ad un'altra persona,
spesso e volentieri anche uno sconosciuto,
perché noi mischiamo le persone,
cioè facciamo proprio interagire,
è un qualcosa che dentro
ti fa cambiare il modo di ragionare.
Diventi più forte,
hai voglia di metterti in gioco
in maniera diversa
su tutti i vari problemi
che si possono presentare
nel corso della vita.
E questa è il terzo tipo di bellezza,
secondo me, quello che più mi appartiene.
Sono passata da una bellezza apparente,
che è una bellezza
che mi ha fatto soffrire,
mi ha fatta crescere.
Ho trovato la mia bellezza,
che è una bellezza emozionale,
che mi permette, attraverso la danza,
di riuscire a stare bene io,
di volermi bene io.
E, volendomi bene io,
riuscire ad essere una buona persona
anche nei confronti
e nei rapporti con gli altri.
E poi ho scoperto la mia di bellezza,
la risposta a tutte le mie domande.
Una bellezza unica,
perché io sono una persona unica:
porto in viso i segni di una malattia,
porto in viso i segni
di mesi, anni, tre anni
di chemioterapia, laserterapia,
radioterapia, operazioni, etc. etc. etc.
Tante domande, tanta
sofferenza, però sono qui.
Sono una bellezza unica.
Ho una storia da raccontare,
ho raggiunto i miei obiettivi,
li ho fatti con centinaia
di migliaia di persone.
E quello che a me piace
del lavoro che faccio,
al di là della danza in sé,
è riuscire ad aiutare le altre persone
a trovare la loro, di bellezza.
Quella bellezza interiore
che ci fa sognare.
Quella bellezza interiore che ci permette
di sentirci persone complete,
di dire sì, anche io
ce la posso fare!
Io ce la faccio!
Perché nessuno al mondo può dirci
che non possiamo fare qualcosa.
Noi possiamo fare
tutto quello che vogliamo.
I limiti sono una semplice
concezione mentale,
ce li poniamo da soli i limiti.
Ma se noi non sogniamo, non viviamo!
E non c'è niente di più bello al mondo
che avere un grande sogno
e a piccoli, piccoli passi,
riuscire a raggiungere
questo grande sogno.
Voi, che siete un pubblico meraviglioso,
siete il mio grande sogno raggiunto.
L'ennesimo passo avanti
nell’obiettivo della mia vita,
nel portare un messaggio,
nel riuscire a farvi uscire da questa sala
pensando e avendo un concetto di bellezza
diverso da quello con il quale
siete entrati qui dentro.
Io sono un'amante,
tra l'altro, della moda.
Quindi, pensate
quanto è stato difficile per me
riuscire ad entrare in un mondo
dove tutto è standardizzato,
dove tutto è inquadrato.
Eppure, ce l’ho fatta!
Perché, per fortuna,
ci sono persone che sognano,
persone che hanno la mente aperta
quindi molto open-mind,
persone che hanno deciso,
attraverso la mia figura, la mia persona,
di non rappresentare la classica modella
ma di far indossare un abito
a una donna che ha qualcosa da raccontare.
Dare un significato anche
alla creazione di altri artisti,
raccontare una storia, una storia potente,
un storia ricca di emozioni.
Una storia ricca di bellezza,
perché la bellezza, signori,
ce l'abbiamo dentro!
Ognuno di noi è bello,
ed è bello a modo suo.
E se ve lo dico io, fidatevi, è vero.
Perché è veramente difficile
riuscire a vivere in un mondo
dove ti senti, ogni giorno,
giudicato.
E allora io voglio
che le persone mi giudichino,
mi metto su un palco
e racconto la mia storia.
Perché se mi dovete giudicare,
lo dovete fare per la persona che sono
e per la storia che ho da raccontarvi.
E non solo per il mio aspetto.
Questo per farvi ragionare
su come ognuno di noi
abbia il diritto e il dovere
di volersi bene.
Sentirsi bello e amarsi,
perché soltanto in questo modo
possiamo vedere il bello
nelle altre persone.
Grazie.
(Applausi)